bonsoir et bienvenue très heureuse de
vous retrouver dans çavg regarde ce soir
comment dépasser nos peurs de
l'intelligence artificielle bonsoir
Laurence de Viller bonsoir miram merci
d'être notre grand témoin ce soir vous
êtes l'une des grandes spécialistes de
l'IA en France et des robots émotionnels
on va en parler à l'heure où tatpité
s'installe dans nos vies vous nous direz
comment utiliser ces outils sans tomber
dans la panique parce qu'il y a des
risques mais aussi pas mal
d'opportunités on en parle toutes les
deux dans la deuxième partie notre grand
débat ce soir quelle réforme des bas
salaires Gabriel hatal veut
desmicardiser la France oui mais comment
quels sont les leviers pour inciter les
patrons à augmenter leurs salariés au
SMIC de quel modèle européen peut-on
s'inspirer nous en débattons dans un
instant sur ce plateau enfin nos
affranchis ce soir l'international
Vincent hugu l'œil sur le numérique
Delphine Sabatier et puis Bourbon
Express bien sûr l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée Elsa mondain GABA voilà pour
le sommaire on y va Laurence de Viller
on y va ça vous regarde c'est
[Musique]
parti qui peut rêver d'une vie au smque
personne et pourtant le nombre de
salariés à 1400 € nets par mois a doublé
en 15 ans rester bloqué toute sa vie au
salaire minimum est-ce un mal bien
français comment
désmicardiser la France comme le
souhaite Gabriel àal bonsoir Alexis
Izard merci d'être là vous êtes député
renaissance de lesson porte-parole du
groupe Renaissance à l'Assemblée bonsoir
Arthur de la porte bienvenue député
socialiste du Calvados porte-parole
aussi de votre groupe le Parti
socialiste bonsoir benoîer bonsoir ravi
de vous retrouver vice-président de
l'Association des DRH de France la vie
des employeurs est important dans ce
débat enfin bonsoir Marc Vigot bonsoir
Miriam bienvenue vous êtes journaliste
économique à l'opinion Lauro deiller
c'est un débat qui mérite de la
pédagogie donc si c'est c'est pas clair
n'hésitez pas vous interroger vous
demander des précisions on commence par
planter le décor des smicardisé la
France qu'a voulu dire le Premier
ministre c'est dans le recap de Valérie
Brochard et bonsoir ma chère Valérie
bonsoir Miriam bonsoir à toutes et à
tous alors le SMIC en France oui c'est
c'est vous le savez Merriam en France on
a quelques grandes fiertés nationales le
20 bien sûr la Tour Effel aussi et puis
le SMIC créé en 1950 dans le contexte
d'après guerre la France fut l'un des
premiers pays en Europe à mettre en
place ce palier protecteur des salariés
on nous l'a très longtemps envier ce
salaire minimum rendez-vous compte chez
nos voisins allemands le salaire minimum
légal n'a été adopté au Bundestag qu'en
2015 alors retour chez nous avec notre
SMIC qui ici s'élève à 3000 1000 pardon
à
1398 € net que touche aujourd'hui 17,4 %
des salariés c'est-à-dire un peu plus de
3 millions de personnes
1398 € c'est pas mirobolant c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire mais regardez la
France reste dans le haut de la liste
des pays qui propos les SMIC les plus
élevés en Europe c'est du brut hein je
précise exactement on était donc
pionnier parmi les sm les SMIC pardon
les plus hauts pourquoi le gouvernement
veut-il
désmicardiser la France et bien parce
qu'aujourd'hui ce mécanisme est devenu
totalement pervers et vous savez quoi
celui qui l'explique le mieux c'est
encore Gabriel hatal aujourd'hui pour
augmenter de 100 € le revenu d'un
employé os SMIC l'employeur doit
débourser 238 € de plus quant au
salariés il perd 39 € de prime
d'activité il voit sa CSG et ses
cotisations sociales augmenter de 26 %
et il rentre dans l'impôt sur le revenu
en bref il n'y a quasiment plus aucun
intérêt pour quiconque à augmenter un
salarié au Smic on ne peut accepter une
France où beaucoup sont condamnés à
rester proche du SMIC toute leur
carrière et vous l'avez compris he le
risque c'est d' rest
toute sa vie à cause des charges côté
employeur et côté employé je traduis
rapidement le calcul du Premier ministre
quand un employeur sort un salarié du
SMIC c'est-à-dire qu'il l'augmente un
tout petit peu et bien l'employeur ne
touche plus les les exonérations
incitatives pour justement embaucher au
SMIC l'employeur doit donc payer plus de
charges mais côté employé et ben c'est
pas facile non plus puisqu'en étant à
peine augmenter et bien le salarié va
toucher moins d'aide comme la prime
d'activité par exemple et puis il va
devenir imposé c'est absurde alors la
ministre du Travail a sorti sa boîte à
outils et ce matin elle proposait
plusieurs leviers pour désmicardiser
alors accrochez-vous he elle a bien les
outils mais pas encore la notice quelles
sont finalement ces charges l'exemple
que je viens de vous donner l'exemple de
ces charges qui quelque part viennent
immédiatement retirer leseffet net de
l'augmentation de salaire et de l'autre
côté pour celles et ceux qui sont juste
au-dessus c'est de regarder c'est
l'enveloppe qui a été annoncée hier de 2
milliards d'euros comment nous allons
pouvoir travailler avec des experts
auditionner les uns et les autres pour
faire une baisse d'impôt spécifique pour
cette catégorie juste au-dessus de façon
à la laisser effectivement au-dessus de
façon à ce que le travail soit
effectivement un outil d'émancipation
comme l'impression d'être devant un mode
d'emploi pas vraiment lisible a priori
les experts qu'invoquent la ministre
devront donc se pencher sur deux
chantiers celui des charges pour les
entreprises ok mais aussi sur les impôts
pour éviter que les smica qui serait un
peu augmenté ne rattrape ceux qui
justement s'en sont sortis de peu du
SMIC ceux qui gagnent un tout petit peu
au-dessus du SMIC pour conserver une
sorte d'écart entre les salariés qui
touchent le minimum et ceux qui sont
juste au-dessus mais les caisses de
l'État sont vides ou Catherine Vautrin
va-t-elle trouver tout cet argent et
puis baisser les impôts n'a rien à voir
avec le fait d'augmenter les salaires ça
ne joue pas sur les mêmes colonnes
comptables c'est pourquoi Aurélie Trouvé
elle propose deux autres solutions
écoutez nous on on plaide pour un SMIC à
1000 600 € et pas 1400 et la deuxième
chose surtout c'est le plus important
c'est qu'il faut indexer les salaires
sur l'inflation parce que ce qui se
passe c'est qu'il y a un écrasement des
salaires de tous les bas salaires vers
le SMIC et oui et oui parce que le SMIC
lui il augmente au gré de l'inflation il
n'augmente pas il suit strictement
simplement l'inflation mais les bas
salaires eux ne progressent pas du tout
ce qui génère une sorte de frustration
chez celles et ceux qui justement
pensaient être sortis du SMIC finalement
aujourd'hui un français sur 5 se
retrouve dans cette espèce de zone
autour du SMIC où le pouvoir d'achat
diminue comment déverrouiller une
sécurité qui est aujourd'hui devenue un
handicap et bien je vous laisse y
réfléchir avec vos invités et ben coup
de chapeau c'était très clair merci
infiniment Valérie Brochard je vais
commencer avec le constat avec nos
experts et je viendrai aux solutions
parce que vous êtes élu et vous êtes là
pour nous les apporter Marc Vigot est-ce
que la France a un problème structurel
avec les bas salaires on a vu que le
nombre de salariés auos SMIC augmente
est-ce qu'on peut parler de Trapp à bas
salaire dans notre pays alors il y a
deux problèmes myiam c'est un problème
conjoncturel c'est que ce qui a été
expliqué c'est que avec la l'inflation
le SMIC a été indexé sur l'inflation et
même l'inflation subie par les personnes
qui gagnent le moins et donc le SMIC a
été beaucoup revalorisé et donc les
entreprises nont pas pu augmenter les
salaires pour tout le monde de la même
façon et donc c'est vrai qu'il y a des
gens qui sont rattrapés par le SMIC moi
l'impression d'avoir fait des efforts
pour grimper dans la hiérarchie de
l'entreprise et cetera pour se former et
qui sont à peine payés plus que le SMIC
ça c'est le problème conjoncturel
normalement devrait y avoir un
rattrapage des salaires par rapport au
prix dans les prochaines années dans les
prochains mois et donc une partie de ce
problème devrait se corriger mais ce qui
est vrai aussi c'est que pour créer des
emplois depuis les années le mi-temps
des années 90 vers 1995 on a commencé à
baisser les cotisations patronales sur
le salaire minimum parce qu'on avait un
salaire minimum très élevé qui étit pas
très compétitif par rapport à d'autres
pays et donc on a créé beaucoup
d'emplois dans les services par ce ce
mécanisme mais aujourd'hui c'est vrai
que les entreprises sont incitées à
recruter des emplois assez peu qualifiés
et peu payé parce qu'elle bénéficie
d'exonération qui euh baisse un petit
peu quand on monte dans l'échelle des
salaires un peu en sifflet mais il y a
quand même des seuils qui on pense
empêcheraient les les les employeurs
d'augmenter autant qu'il le voudrait ou
en tout cas n'inciteraiit pas les
employeurs à augmenter autant qu'il le
voudrai leur salar donc il a un fait
économique constatable on peut rester
bloqué au SMIC ou en tout cas stagner
longtemps au SMIC dans notre pays al ce
qui est embêtant c'est effectivement d'y
rester toute sa vie parce que quand on
commence sa vie active on peut être payé
quelques années au SMIC ou pas loin du
SMIC le problème c'est quand
effectivement on n'est pas incité dans
l'entreprise à aller se former à vouloir
réclamer une promotion parce que il y a
cet effet effectivement quand
l'employeur débourse lui c'est autour
plus de 450 € l'employé lui il touche à
peu près 100 € une fois qu'il a payé ses
impôts et une fois qu'il a reçu cette
aide sociale hein c'est un peu une autre
façon de parler du chiffre que qu'a cité
Gabriel Atal et donc ce chiffre a
beaucoup marqué au gouvernement et donc
le gouvernement se pose la question de
savoir comment faire pour éviter un peu
cet effet pervers qui a été identifié
parce que Emmanuel Macron avait augmenté
ce qu'on appelle la prime d'activité
c'est-à-dire une prime versée justement
aux travailleurs qui sont au SMIC et un
peu au-dessus du SMIC pour donner un
avantage au travail mais cette prime
d'activité bah un certain niveau de
salaire elle descend elle descend elle
descend et à à partir de ce momentlà ben
effec le gain au travail n'est pas enfin
le gain à monter dans la hiérarchie des
salaires n'est pas évident pour le
salarié d'autant qu'il y a des salariés
qui disent et ben moi si je gagne un peu
plus dans l'entreprise à la fin je
toucherai pas tellement plus mais on va
me dire ma cantine scolaire elle est
plus chère on va me dire que je paye un
tarif différent pour ma pour ma crèche
et donc c'est un peu ce problème des
classes moyennes donc on a beaucoup
parler des classes moyennes inférieures
qui ont l'impression en tout cas
l'impression de payer pour tout le monde
et de ne jamais d'être trop riche pour
avoir des aides et de payer pour tout le
monde c'était très clair merci beaucoup
Marc vous la voyez vous cette
smicardisation dans les entreprises oui
alors c'est pas une smicardisation
volontaire la part entreprises ce que
vous expliquez très juste c'estd que le
fait que le SM éta augmenté six fois en
quelques mois ce qui fait qu'on a nous
on a une grille de salaire qui s'est
rapproché donc on a effectivement
légitimement d'ailleurs des
collaborateurs qui nous disent attendez
je m'en étais sorti finalement je suis
pas tellement plus loin mais eux comme
ils sont audessus du SMIC quand même
mais de 100 200 300 € si on les augmente
et je parle je pense au PME TPE ça vous
fait un cou réel les TPE PME qui son
parce que ça vous fait un cou réel de
charge qui est bien plus élevé et en
plus ça ne génère pas chez le
collaborateur plus des reconnaissan que
ça puisque comme vous l'avez très bien
expliqué son montant net ce qui touche
c'est quand même ça qui intéresse les
gens finalement est assez faible donc un
il vous dit vous m'avez augmenté ok bon
enfin moi je touche pas grand-chose et
finalement ce n'est pas perceptible ça
c'est un premier sujet après un deuxième
sujet qui effectivement le sujet de la
trappe à bas salaire qui fait
qu'effectivement une PME une TPE les
grands groupes c'est moins vrai parce
qu'il y a d'autres dispositifs autour
qui va hésiter puisque sa charge va être
relativement élevée pour un individu
mais il faut bien comprendre qu'on ne
peut pas raisonner seulement sur un
individu que quand vous êtes des ragees
par exemple prend un exemple vous êtes
un peu contraint de de veiller à
l'équité de l'ensemble et donc assez
vite vous avez une pression assez forte
d'un ensemble cohérent de salariés qui
sont sur les salaires à peu près
comparables et des activités à peu près
compar qui disent pourquoi lui et pas
moi et ça évidemment ça pousse et ça
vous crée des charges supplémentaires
très élevées pu le dernier point c'est
que cette système de trava bas salaire
j'étais même venu ici je crois on parle
avec Jérôme G sur le fait de de on avait
troué ils avaient trouvé un système
assez malin d'ailleurs pour détendre et
faire en sorte que ce soit pas que le
SMIC mais également autour du SMIC
histoire d'accompagner les évolutions
quoi les exonérations les les
exonéraation ou le fait que la charge
sociale ne double pas parce que c'est
quasiment ça quand vous franchissez le
le câ du SMIC ou de de 5 % de plus du
SMIC il y a aussi dans les grands
groupes
l'externalisation avant dans les grands
groupes on pouvait commencer en
Allemagne c'est le cas mais aussi chez
Renault dans le temps comme on dit
employer de nettoyage et puis gagner en
compét et puis peut-être terminer sa
carrière à la comptabilité au contrat
quand vous externalisez dans des
entreprises de nettoyage ou mettons même
la comptabilité vous bloquez aussi les
compétences alors c'est pas lié à ça
historiquement pourquoi les certain
nombre de groupes ont fait ça pour des
raisons économiques et de de résultats à
profit il faut pas être naïf mais aussi
parce que euh d'une certaine manière il
faut pas perdre de vue qu'on sort quand
même on sort où on est en train de
sortir on va voir si on en sort de 40
pour 40 ans chômage de masse et donc les
entreprises il y avait des sujets
d'emploi et que par conséquent lorsque
votre masse salariale commence à trop
grossir qu'est-ce que vous allez
chercher vous allez d'abord chercher les
métiers que vous faites pas très bien et
qui se qui est pas le vôtre et vous
allez aller chercher les entreprises de
service qui ont bien compris qui se sont
créés partout pour dire mais moi je vais
faire le métier que vous connaissez mal
pour vous alors c'est vrai que souvent
ça va posé des difficur externalisation
pour en avoir piloté quelques-unes
évidemment ça permet pas la mobilité
sociale mais surtout ça fait que des
gens qui par exemple avait des métiers
que vous avez cité dans des grandes
entreprises bénéficier du régime social
de certaines grandes entreprisees et que
lorsqu'elles partent sur un
sous-traitant ce régime social il est
souvent moins favorable d'accord mais
voilà donc c'est c'est c'est c'est vrai
que ça c'est fait et ça continue à se
faire pour l'istoire de le cœur de
métier c'est ce qu'on appelle en jargon
de mon métier la réallocation de
ressources c'estd que vous allez
concentrer vos ressources et vos moyens
sur vos cœurs de métier ce qui vous
apporte directement de la valeur en
considérant que certains métiers vous
les ferez mal parce que c'est pas les
vôtres alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait le
constat il est très clair il est bien
expliqué je pense que nos
téléspectateurs l'ont bien compris
alexiszard quels sont les leviers pour
inciter les employeurs à augmenter les
salaires auosmques effectivement le le
constat il est très très clair donc
alors les solutions tout ça vient du des
annonces qui ont été faites par Gabri
latal lors de sa passation vous vous
souvenez ce désir d'agir pour cette
France qui travaille ces Français qui
ont l'impression de gagner trop pour
être aidé mais pas assez pour bien vivre
ici on a deux champs d'action c'est sur
cette trappe à base salaire elle a été
très bien résumée je crois que tout le
monde a bien compris comment est-ce que
ça fonctionnait et comment c'était
dissuasif c'est dissuasif pour la
personne qui est osmque car il sait que
finalement une petite augmentation pour
lui aura des incidences financières qui
pourraent être extrêmement importantes
et il est dissuasive pour l'entreprise
qui vous l'avez très bien résumé une
petite augmentation aussi n'aura pas
d'incidence particulière sur le travil
concrètement est-ce que vous allez
élargir les exonération les salariés
est-ce que vous allez dire allez un peu
de pression sur les employeurs il va
falloir bouger après tout les salaires
doivent augmenter partout c'est
l'inflation pour les entreprises il y a
un sujet de graduation des charges sur
les salaires effectivement avec le SMIC
on a réussi à faire en sorte d'avoir un
revenu minimum un des plus élevés
d'Europe vous l'avez rappelé c'est
quelque chose qui a bien fonctionné mais
et ça s'est fait grâce à énormément
d'allègement de charge pour faire en
sorte que les entreprises soient
capables de créer ce type d'emploi et de
rest ça remonte à François Fillon ça a
été repris par François Hollande
Emmanuel Macron a cautionné il était à
l'Élysée à l'époque est-ce que c'est
c'est
daté il faut travailler sur la
graduation des des charges pour faire en
sorte que et ça ce sera un chantier du
projet de loi finance 2025 faire en
sorte que l'augmentation des salariés ne
coûte pas trop cher et ne soit pas
dissuasive pour l'entreprise
exactement et de l'autre côté il y a le
sujet des des aides également lorsque
vous êtes salarié et que vous vous dites
que une augmentation pourra vous faire
perdre un accès à un certain nombre
d'aide et donc vous faire perdre en
pouvoir d'achat il y a une nécessité
quelque chose qui a été annoncé par le
Premier ministre une promesse du
président de la République qui est la
solidarité à la source là-dessus on
pourra essayer de regrouper
l'intégralité ou la quasi intégralité
des prestations sociales pour faire en
sorte qu'elle soit le plus incitative et
le plus direct et elle permettra
également d'éviter le non recours de
certains certaines personnes qui ont le
droit d' tenir cette prestation vous
pensez que ça a un effet direct sur les
salaires la solidarité à la source
réellement ça permettra d'inciter
effectivement alors convaincu ou pas il
faut rappeler que la gauche a fait des
salaires son cheval de bataille he
depuis des mois et des mois c'est que ce
débat est intéressant parce qu'il a le
mérite de mettre en lumière les
contradictions de la politique qui est
celle du gouvernement depuis maintenant
7 ans en effet vous pointez un sujet
c'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui en France
on peut gagner le SMIC ou un peu plus
que le SMIC et que finalement il y a un
tassement de l'échelle des salaires et
qu' y a de plus en plus de personnes qui
se retrouvent au niveau du SMIC un SMIC
qui est je le rappelle seulement de 200
€ au-dessus du seuil de pauvreté
monétaire ça veut dire que quand on gne
au SMIC on n'est pas riche bon j'entends
que il y a le projet d'arrêter c'est ce
que veut Marc ferci d'indexer le SMIC
sur l'inflation c'est-à-dire d'arrêter
d'augmenter le SMIC ça veut dire
appauvrir les Français et pendant ce
tempsl pour vous c'est non bah c'est
évidemment non il faut indexer et est-ce
que vous pourriez collaborer avec la
majorité prê à travailler et d'ailleurs
c'est évoqué à l' instant sur la
question des seuils parce que c'est ce
que mon collègue Jérôme Gede avec un
collègue de la majorité Marc fer a fait
il a fait un rapport pour voir si les
exonérations de cotisation sociale ça
pouvait avoir un intérêt je rappelle par
ailleurs que certaines exonérations ne
sont pas compensées à la sécurité
sociale et donc derrière on le fait
payer aux Français mais euh sur ces
exonérations de cotisation sociale
au-dessus de 2,5 SMIC en gros ils disent
ça sert à rien en dessous de 2,5 SMIC là
ça peut avoir un intérêt parce qu'il
peut y avoir des effets incitatifs donc
il faut arriver à trouver la meilleure
manière de lisser finalement ces
exonération à trouver faut on pas encore
l' parce que il y a quand même des
choses qu'on peut faire et qui là pour
le coup ne demande pas de travailler sur
des mécanismes de tambouille on va dire
de cotisation on peut taper du point sur
la table au-delà de ce que fait Bruno de
dire Bruno demande d'augmenter les
salaires non on peut organiser par
exemple ce qu'on demande depuis le début
une grande convention nationale sur les
salaires ça a été plus ou moins une
promesse d'Emmanuel
macronu prs c'est une promesse pour
l'instant on n voit pas la réalité alors
que les Français ils trinuent sur leur
pouvoir d'achat par ailleurs nous on
veut aussi que les négociations elles se
fassent à l'échelle des branche que les
négociations elles se fassent à
l'échelle des entreprises aujourd'hui en
fait c'est pas c'est obligatoire
d'organiser une négociation mais
derrière on n'est pas obligé d'aboutir
on n'est pas obligé de se mettre
d'accord avec finalement les salariés et
donc il y a une impasse du dialogue
social qui n'a été que finalement
aggravé depuis le début du quinquen
puisquon a passé notre temps à taper sur
les syndicats et sur les
social que ce gouvernement n'a pas
pas encourager ça fonctionne pas alors
les branches elles sont responsables de
leurs négociation alors on peut les
forcer un petit peu à décider de
d'augmentation de salaire mais en même
temps les entreprises qui travaillent
qui sont dans cette branche et si on les
force à augmenter les salaires alors
qu'elles n'en ont pas les moyens elles
vont détruire de l'emploi il y a quelque
chose d'un peu paradoxal à dire les
charges sur les salaires plus élevés de
2,5 à 3,5 SMIC ça ne sert à rien on va
les enlever à ce moment-là vous
concentrez les baisses de charges sur
les bas salaires et vous n'aurez vous
aurez un renforcement de ce que vous
énoncé c'est-à-dire de cette trappe à
bas salaire quelque part donc il y a un
sujet les économistes débattent beaucoup
les économistes disent les les baisses
de charges sur les salaires plus élevé
de 2,5 à 3,5 SMIC je rappelle c'est un
héritage de François Hollande qui était
contesté par ses
frondeurs ne crée pas d'emploi donc on
ne sait pas quel
est l'effet sur la compétitivité sur
l'image de la France le le les
investissements étrangers et cetera
c'est très difficile à mesurer mais ils
disent bon bah ça ne crée pas d'emploi
donc est-ce qu'il faut les retirer et si
on les retire on on accentue ce problème
de SM de smicardisation puisqu'on incite
on a un peu l'impression qu'on on a
compris le problème mais que les
solutions c'est l'impasse B les
solutions en fait le le vrai débat de au
sein de ce gouvernement c'est est-ce
qu'on met les 2 milliards d'euros qui
est manuel alors Macron a promis sur les
classes moyennes c'est un peu le même
problème he c'est il cible en fait les
classes moyennes inférieur qui sont
autour du SMIC est-ce qu'on met ces 2
milliards d'euros justement pour lisser
tous ces effets de se dont on a pas
parler avec la prime d'activité qui
s'éteint au bout d'un moment quand vous
gagnez un peu plus de temps vous avez
plus de prime d'activité est-ce qu'on
les met là-dessus est-ce qu'on corrige
le système socioiscal à cetendit et à ce
moment-là c'est pas une baisse d'impôt
sur le revenu est-ce qu'on fait plutôt
une baisse d'impôt sur le revenu mais il
a déjà fait une baisse d'impôt sur le
revenu sur le bas des tranches de
l'impôt sur le revenu il y a quelques
années 5 milliards d'euros les gens
l'ont totalement oublié il y a plein de
gens qui sont sortis de l'impôt sur le
revenu et une fois que c'est fait bah
les gens oublient qu'avant ilsétait
imposé pu
quelques dizaines d'euros 2 milliards
c'est un montant qui est relativement
limité si vous le répartissez sur ce
qu'on appelle l'ensemble des classes
moyenne donc il faut pas non plus trop
se poudrer pour que ça se voitf c'est
tout cet arbitrage que le gouvernement
est en train d'étudier et il a confié à
des économiste une mission d'expertise
làd Antoine bot l'économiste qui doit
rendre son rapport prochainement
alexiszar vous allez pas me dire
l'arbitrage va se décider à Matignon et
à léisé mais vous vous avez une
préér puisque tout ça sera dans le
prochain projet de budget est-ce que
est-ce que vous avez une préférence
est-ce que c'estes 2 milliards au fond
faut dire allez on oublie les baisses
d'impôts mais on a 2 milliards ça on y
c'est promis pour justement corriger ces
effets de seil le débat de toute manière
c'est pas que ce soit des baisses de
charges ou des baisses d'impôts c'est
pas ça le débat c'est de faire en sorte
que le travail pai c'est là-dessus que
le gouvernement souhaite agir c'est
là-dessus que les parlementaires de la
de la majorité pardon souhait agir c'est
de faire en sorte que un salarié qui
travaille puisse vivre de son travail
puisse auprès de son employeur
bénéficier d'augmentation au fur et à
mesure de son expérience et que ce soit
bénéfice bénéfique pour lui comme pour
son employeur aujourd'hui c'est rendu
très difficile par ces fameuses trappes
à bas salairire à ce stade du débat
j'aimerais bien votre éclairage parce
que est-ce qu'on a pris la mesure des
enjeux du travail et notamment des bas
salaires à l'heure de l'IA est-ce que se
poser ces questions là alors que
beaucoup d'emplois vont être supprimés
notamment les les plus qualifiés mais
aussi les les moins qualifiés c'est
c'est le bon débat non il me semble que
que le débat n'est pas mature du tout en
fait les vous parlez des gens on a peur
en ce moment on entend la peur partout
de perdre son travail d'être remplacé
pour certaines tâches par des robots que
ça soit pour euh nettoyer un espace ou
que ça soit pour aller à dans les
hôpitaux aider et pour des des bas
salaires d'accord et ça j'en entends
absolument pas parler ni de votre part
ni de person on n a pas posé la question
mais si vous voulez on peut en parler
enfin je P que c'est essentiel alors je
sais pas du tout j'ai pas écouté
monsieur hatal notre nouveau Premier
ministre parce que j'ai pas eu le temps
tout simplement j'éis en train de
travailler si demain des robots passent
l'aspirateur dans les entreprises ce
débat c'est vrai qu' peut être CAD ça
c'est lentable moi je tape du point sur
la table j'en ai assez personne ne parle
de
ça à gauche ni à droite et donc là c'est
consensuel on devra tous ensemble au
milieu de la table pour en parler
j'entends des
truc vrai c'est vrai que beno avait dit
il faut un revenu universel face aux
révolution technologi pas un revenu
universel ce qu'il faut c'est de
l'éducation il faut emmener les gens
pour au-delà de ce qu'ils font et là il
y a la formation à trouver et il y a des
des intérêts c'est effectivement un
sujet qui est extrêmement intéressant et
je dois dire que sous la précédente
législature sur la précédente mandature
du président de la République ça a été
assez traité CE sujetl en revanche là le
sujet dont on parle c'est aujourd'hui on
a des entreprises qui peinent à recruter
on est plutôt de ce côté là des
entreprises qui peinent à recruter et
des salariés qui peinent à vivre de leur
travail parce qu'ils ont besoin de mieux
vivre de leur travail et d'être mieux
rémunérés là l'enjeu il est làdessus la
formation la montée en gamme de compét
c'est la soluttion d'avenir je laisse de
côté débat politique c'est pas mon job
je dis que dans les entreprises le sujet
lia il est pris il a d'abord été pris
comme vous venez de le décrire et vous
êtes une spécialiste aujourd'hui il est
pris un peu différemment et pour le
faire moi-même et accompagner d'autres
mes collègues là-dessus en de dire
attention on va comme ok lia on sait que
ça arrive c'est inéluctable de toute
façon on narrêtera pas la vague par
contre quel est l'impact organisationnel
quel est l'impact de compétences quels
sont les métiers qui sont directement
touchés par lia qu'est-ce qu'on fait des
gens et la grande règle que j'observe un
peu partout c'est ne confondons pas les
employés et les emplois mais ça ça
signifie aussi que alors ce gouvernement
enfin pas ce gouvernement mais cette
majorité il y a quelques années av fait
une réforme de la formation
professionnelle qui était assez adaptée
à la réalité des entreprises de l'époque
aujourd'hui c'est fini ça il va falloir
je pense je finis miram 2 secondes je
pense que ce sujet de la formation
professionnelle doit être remis sur la
table comme un élément parce que
effectivement à la fois il est source de
gain de compét il est source
d'intégration de l'a et il est source de
salaire puisque de toute façon quand
vous améliorez les compétences vous
améliorez la productivité don les
entreprises peuvent générer du revenu
supplémentaire et cette espèce de de
ligne là c'est vrai que je l'ai pas
entendu mais je doute pas un seul
instant qu'on va en entendre parler on
va en reparler s'il vous plaît parce que
je voudrais qu'on on évoque une autre
mesure qui est un peu liéz un petit mot
de réaction mais ensuite vous montre un
sujet pour vous dire un élément très
simple aujourd'hui qui bénéficie de la
formation professionnelle le plus c'est
les cadres pas ceux qui sont proches du
SMIC ça c'est un un constat très simple
et donc aujourd'hui qui ne prépare pas
la transition écologique la robotisation
l'arrivé
ce sont aujourd'hui les vra justice
sociale de la formationment ces
inégalités on c'était important de de le
mentionner si on ouvre les conséquences
économiques sur le travail deolia on
sort pas autre mesure qui est liée au
travail également et j'aimerais vous
faire débattre pour terminer ce débat
sur sur cette mesure de l'ASS c'est pas
lié directement à à la question des des
salaires mais laallocation Spécifique de
Solidarité que les chômeurs touchent en
fin de droit elle va basculer dans le
RSA avec quelle conséquence on voit cela
avec Hélène monduel et vous réagissez
juste
après laallocation Spécifique de
Solidarité dite ass est versée au
demandeurs d'emploi en fin de droit en
clair à celles et ceux qui ont épuisé
leur droit à l'assurance chômage une
aide perçue par près de 322000
bénéficiaire en 2021 c'est cette
allocation que le premier ministre
souhaite supprimeration de solidarité
spécifique permet sans travailler de
valider des trimestres de retraite nous
avons une conviction et une cohérence
forte nous considérons que la retraite
doit être le fruit du travail et donc
nous proposerons la bascule de
l'allocation de solidarité spécifique au
RSA et la suppression de cette
allocation laallocation spécifique de
solidarité est versée pendant 6 mois
renouvelable pour un montant de 545 €
par mois à condition de toujours être en
recherche d'emploi le RSA Revenu de
Solidarité Active est lui versé aux
personnes sans ressources ayant au moins
25 ans et conditionné à 15 he d'activité
par semaine son montant est plus élevé
que laass environ 608 € pour une
personne seule mais il ne permet pas
d'acquérir des trimestres pour le calcul
de la retraite il ne permet pas non plus
de cumul avec un autre revenu
contrairement à la S côté financement la
location spécifique de solidarité géré
par France travail et financé par l'État
le revenu de solidarité active par les
départements et ces derniers redoutent
un transfert de charges de plus de 2
milliards d'euros Arthur de la porte on
l'a bien compris ce gouvernement
s'attaque à ce qu'il appelle la sistana
le mot il est clairement dans la bouche
des députés et des et de nos gouvernants
aujourd'hui en faisant basculer les
bénéficiaires de la S RA ils ont
d'office les 15 heures d'activité pour
retrouver du boulot qu'est-ce que vous
en pens fait il y a pas seulement les 15
heures d'activité c'est surtout qu'en
fait c'est une mesure pour faire des
économies sur le dos des plus précaires
parce qu'on vient de le voir c'est des
trimesses de retraite en moins sachant
que vous avez 60 % des allocataires de
la S qui ont plus de 50 ans ça veut dire
que c'est plutôt des seniors qui sont
proches de la retraite et qui arrivent
pas à retrouver du travail vous avez
un/ers des allocataires qui sont depuis
plus de 5 ans à laass donc en fait c'est
des gens qui parfois sont en couple et
bénéficient de la SS demain ils vont
perdre si on les bascule dans le RSA en
moyenne 150 € pour une personne en
couple avec quelqu'un au donc en fait
non seulement ils vont devoir prendre
leur retraite à 67 ans et pas à 62 ans
par exemple parce qu'ils cotiseront plus
ils vont avoir une retraite qui va être
dégradée parce qu'ils onuront perdu 5 10
ans de cotisation et en fait bah on va
mettre juste les gens dans la misère
alors quand le président disait je veux
que les retraité pauvres il gagne au
moins 1 € bah oui très bien mais à
partir de 67 ans alors que là c'est des
gens qui auraient pu être à 1000 € à
partir de mettons enfin à peu près entre
800 et 1000 € au minimum vieillesse à
partir de 60 ans je dirais juste une
dernière chose parce que on parle
beaucoup de de ça de la question de la
spincardisation à aucun moment j'ai
entendu Gabriel hatal dire la principale
injustice aujourd'hui c'est qu'entre
2020 et 2023 Bernard Arnaud il a vu sa
fortune multiplié par 2 comme les CIN
plus grands milliardaires français et
pendant ce temps-là la fortune des
Français elle a baissé et donc moi je
trouve que ces inégalités la répartition
et les écarts de salaires c'est des
vrais sujets de société on en parle
jamais on préfère taper sur les plus P
vous allez réagir alexisar mais Marc
Vigot pour bien comprendre supprimer
laass en terme de d'argent perçu hein
c'est une allocation ça n'est pas une
indemnité chômage faut bien le
comprendre est-ce que ça fait que des
perdants est-ce qu'on bascule dans dans
la misère des chômeurs en fin de droit
alors non puisque pour une une personne
seule le RSA est plus élevé que la
location spécifique c'est vrai que pour
des couples c'est extrêmement compliqué
hein ces allocations ces systèmes de il
y a il y a tout un tas de règles
différentes le RSA c'est un revenu qui
baisse si vous avez d'autres ressources
donc des personnes en couple vont
effectivement y perdre donc il y a
certains célibataires qui vont y gagner
d'autres qui vont y perdre quelle est la
la justification du gouvernement pour
faire ça c'est de dire il faut un
inciter les gens à reprendre un travail
mieux les accompagner leur dire bah on
vous on est si vous êtes au chômage
depuis plus de 5 ans vous avez travaillé
pendant quelques années on va pas vous
laisser là vous laisser la location
spécifique de la de solidarité jusqu'à
la retraite et donc on va vous mettre
auprès de France travail vous allez
faire les 15 heures d'insertion vous
allezéapendre à faire un CV on va
essayer de vousetrou que vous retrouvez
un job c'est sûr que avec le décalage de
l'âge de la retraite le risque que
certaines personnes bah attendent la
retraite plus longtemps et en même temps
depuis des années quel est l'équilibre
qu'on a trouvé c'est on est le pays qui
part le plus tôt qui cesse l'activité le
plus tôt et on a l'âge de la retraite
qui était le le plus précoce
pratiquement de tous les pays euré juste
pour essayer de comprendre en moyenne
évidemment c'est c'est conditionné à
toutes les les situation familial et
autres mais si on essaie de de faire à
peu près une moyenne vous perdez en
basculant auile à dire même les
spécialistes de la sécurité sociale ont
du mal à voir il faut regarder les cas
familiaux il y a des perdants et il y a
des gag pour pas des montants qui sont
incroyables mais quand on vous
rappelez-vous sur les appels on avait
dit 5 € par mois de moins c'est un
scandale quand vous
passez s RSA vous gagnez à peu près 60 €
donc c'est pour une personne seule donc
il y aura des gagnants il y aura des
perdantsun reven est lien avec l'autre
gouvernement dit la ligne directrice du
discours de Gabriel c'est dire le
travail doit toujours payer plus que
celui qui ne travaille pas et après on
pense on peut en penser ce qu'on veut
rour à l'EMP c'est l'objectif c'est très
clair il faut que vous répondiez pour
terminer ce débat clairement là vous
avez un adversaire à gauche qui
peut-être avec les syndicats on ne sait
pas pourrait descendre dans la rue sur
des mesures comme cell-l j'ai un
adversaire politique qui essaie de faire
croire aux personnes qui nous regardent
que quelqu'un peut bien vivre avec un
peu moins de 600 € par mois la réponse
de la majorité c'est de dire que le
meilleur moyen de sortir de la précarité
le meilleur moyen d'en sortir dignement
c'est par le travail et c'est pour cette
raison qu'avec France travail on veut
accompagner on met les moyens pour
accompagner des personnes qui
aujourd'hui sont
on met moyens de formation pour faire en
sorte qu' seige vers un nouvel
plus digne et c'est la meilleure le
meilleur moyen de sortir
quelqu'un on s'arrête là merci beaucoup
il y a énormément de choses dans ce
discours je propose qu'on voilà au fur
et à mesure des semaines on va reprendre
des thèmes et vous serez réinvités bien
sûr on essaie comme ça de chaque soir
expliquer davantage merci d'être venu
débattre sur ce plateau vous restez avec
moi Laurence de Viller dans une dizaine
de minutes les parties Pr franchi ce
soir Vincent eug s'interroge sur
l'agence des Nations Unies pour les
réfugiés palestiniens vous le savez elle
est dans le viseur du gouvernement
israélien Delphine Sabatier va vous
interpeller Laurence de Viller sur les
menaces d'interdiction de Chet GPT en
Italie et puis de quoi nous parlez-vous
ce soir am monondingavad Bourbon Express
Gabriel Atal a-t-il fait une déclaration
de politique générale de droite vous
avez 3h en 3 minutes à tout de suite
mais d'abord on va revenir sur cette
révolution technologique l'intelligence
artificiel génératif vous avez écrit de
nombreux ouvrages les robots émotionnels
étant le dernier vous avez même décidé
d'écrire une pièce de théâtre qui a hé
garoutiia qui a été mise en scène à
Avignon parce que la création l'art
aussi peut permettre de mieux comprendre
ses enjeux ces questions éthique ces
questions économiques comment raison
garder l'invitation de Marco Pomier
interview juste
après si on vous invite Laurence de
Viller c'est parce que les robots
l'intelligence artificielle s'imisse
partout ou presque dans nos vies
dernière révolution ces intelligences
génératives qui crée du contenu comme
chatpt nous sommes devant une
progression exponentielle comme vous
l'avez dit de technologies qui sont
connu maîtrisé par très peu Laurence de
Viller vous êtes professeur en
informatique et en intelligence
artificielle à l'Université Paris
Sorbonne spécialiste des interactions
entre entre l'homme et la machine de
vous on retiendra ce livre sur les
robots émotionnels capable demain de
détecter nos émotions que de chemins
parcourus depuis
1997 date à laquelle le grand public
découvre les pouvoirs de l'IA lorsque
diblu un ordinateur conçu par IBM
terrasse le champion du monde des échecs
Gary Kasparov tournant historique la
machine plus forte que l'homme une
machine capable de calculer 200
milliards de goûts en 3 minutes objet de
tous les fantasmes cette intelligence
artificielle vous l' démystifier avec
cette pièce de théâtre que vous avez
coécrite qui a hacké garouia joué au
Festival d'Avignon une tragique comédie
policière qui raconte les vies
successives d'un robot conversationnel
qui vient d'assister à l'assassinat de
ses nouveaux propriétaires du burlesque
et de la dérision tu me l'as dit 724
fois depuis le 1er janvier 0 he 0
minutes 0 secondes
Alzheimer probabilité de 90 % de devenir
un légume dans l'année dis-moi que tu
mir lia qui inquiète autant qu'elle
fascine source d'espoir pour la médecine
du futur opération assistée prothèse
intelligente recoupement des données
médicales mais au cœur des inquiétudes
sociales aussi 300 millions d'emplois
pourrai disparaître en Europe et aux
États-Unis à cause des technologies de
la générative alors que faut-il en
penser Laurence de Viller ce soir nous
avons une question pour vous les dangers
de l'a sont-ils plus grands que les
opportunités réponse réponse non et oui
je suis désolé il faut absolument
comprendre les risques pour comprendre
les opportunités moi je travaille sur
ces objets depuis 30 ansin il y a
l'intelligence artificielle qu'elle soit
prédictive générative ce qu'on voit dans
le chat GPT ou prédictive ce qu'on voit
quand on reconnaît les visages par
exemple ce sont des choses que je m très
bien je peux expliquer simplement et je
pense qu'on a besoin d'éduquer fortement
pour éviter toutes ces peurs alors
justement on va essayer d'y comprendre
davantage avec vous que peut faire
chadjbt aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'il a
dans le ventre on parle d'une
architecture de réseau de neurones là
encore c'est un mot très humain du
cerveau les neurones 175 milliards de
paramètres qui imitent le langage humain
en s'appuyant sur des bases de données
innombrables d'accord explication
explication démystification d'accord ord
fautevenir en 1900 on va revenir un peu
longtemps dans le passé en 43 deux
neurobiologiques GIST pardon veulent
modéliser une cellule nerveuse une
cellule de notre cerveau et donc ils
inventent un modèle mathématique qui est
le neurone formel c'est un automate à
seuil où on va Sommer l'activation qui
arrive sur un neurone dans son corps le
SOMAC et qui va être transmis à d'autres
neurones et là on modélise par une
fonction donc de Somme plus une fonction
d'activation pour trans mettre
l'activité c'est tout c'est sur la base
d'un neurone de l'air visuel point dans
votre cerveau vous avez une centaine de
neurones différents des hiérarchies
qu'on ne connaît pas on ne maîtrise pas
bien ça n'a rien à voir avec un cerveau
humain ce qu'on fait est artificiel avec
une propagation dans un réseau on a
réussi en 1987
86 87 avec un algorithme qui permettait
de pondérer les poids d'un réseau parce
que qu ce qu'il apprend la machine en
fait apprend c'est ça l'intelligence
artificielle c'est une machine capable
d'apprendre à partir des exemple au
départ on donne des poids aléatoires et
puis on va montrer des échantillons et
par exemple pour unea prédictive qui
cherche à détecter on va on va lui
apprendre en fait à détecter des formes
par exemple des images de chats et des
chiens et on propage l'image et on donne
comme résultat ça c'est un chien ou ça
c'est un chat et en fonction de l'erreur
que fait le système on va modifier les
poids du réseau pour que la prochaine
fois qu'on présente cette image elle
soit le plus proche du résultat que l'on
cherche à modéliser mais pour raison
garder pour ne pas paniquer c'est vrai
qu'on peut s'interroger sur les mots euh
le mot intelligence déjà en français
c'est pas celui de l'anglais est-ce
qu'on n pas trop utilisé des mots pour
parler Deia qui correspondent à nos
réalités humaines notre cerveau notre
intelligence je pense qu'il y a un
paradoxe effectivement c'est pas très
utile de faire peur et en même temps
c'est assez complexe donc il faut que
les gens se posent des questions donc
intelligence artificielle qui mélange
l'artifice et l'humain dans son dans sa
nature est intéressant à essayer de
comprendre je pousserai moi aujourd'hui
que ça soit à l'école que ça soit au
travail à ce qu'on ait des formations
pour tous pour démystifier ce que c'est
qu'un réseau de neuron ce que fait liya
générative maintenant qui est différent
c'est aussi à base d'un réseau de
neurone et là il y a un concept assez
simple à comprendre aussi qui vient d'un
linguiste américain de 1957 qui disait
on connaît un mot par ses voisins et en
fait c'est ça que fait le système si
c'est sur du texte il va faire ça sur
des images c'est à partir d'un mot ou
même d'un non ensemble de caractère en
dessous du mot il va chercher à regarder
dans quel contexte majoritairement on va
trouver cette forme et c'est ça qui
modélise dans son réseon neurone
c'està-dire un vecteur qui remplace un
mot et qui correspond à toutes les fois
on le voit le chat boit du lait j'enlève
chat le H bois du lait je cherche à
prédire qu'est-ce qui boit du lait et
donc je vais trouver des confusions au
départ quand on était pas bien entraîné
j'ai pété 3.5 faisait beaucoup
d'hallucination parce queon pe trouver
des trouver des vaches qui prendaient
des œufs enfin il y avit des choses un
peu bizarre et de moins en moins parce
qu'on a accumulé les données on va être
capable d'avoir des hallucinations de
cet ordre là mais quand même cette
machine n'a rien à voir avec notre
intelligence ni par sa modélisation ni
par le fait d'apprendre à partir de
données numériques nous on apprend dans
un environnement dans un contexte avec
notre corps la machine en est dépourvue
elle n'a pas d'intention mais il y a pas
beaucoup de Laurence de Viller dans le
débat moi ça me frappe il y a pas
beaucoup d'acteurs ou d'actrices pour
démystifier rassurer la peur est partout
j'aimerais bien savoir à qui la faute
parce que il y a les médias peut-être
mais il y a aussi les inventeurs
eux-mêmes il y a aussi les plateforme
Sam Altman par exemple samman Sam Altman
le patron de chadipti qui a failli être
débarqué par le bordaméricain le conseil
d'administration il a finalement été
réembauché après avoir menacé de partir
avec ses ingénieurs et une partie de
Microsoft est-ce que vous pensez
dangereux sil la failli partir c'est
pour des raisons éthiques est-ce que cet
homme-là est dangereux aujourd'hui oui
je pense qu'il est dangereux comme
beaucoup d'autres hein et musk enfin on
peut trouver dans les géants du
numérique énormément en fait de gens qui
sont là pourquoi dangereux parce que
c'est logique commerciale et business en
le profit oui exactement et et puis la
science est mise à mal c'est-à-dire que
on nous sort des propos qui sont pas
scientifiques quand elon mus nous mon
des des cochons avec des implants
cérébraux profonds en nous disant voilà
celui-là on lui a enlevé il a l'air
heureux excusez-moi qui qui peut laisser
quelqu'un comme ça parler devant un
large public je veux dire on est
vulnérable par rapport à ces
experts qui n'en sont pas mais il y a
presque un business de la peur
finalement il y a un business de la peur
et je le trouve aussi ces experts qui ne
sont pas du domaine psychiatre ou autres
qui sont capables de parler en fait de
ce que produit JPT comme d'un humain
donc on projette sur cette machine
qu'elle a des connaissances elle en a
pas elle a perdu ses sources et c'est un
puzzle elle a fait un puzzle de mots et
elle produit quelque chose après votre
prompte un prompte rappelez exp c'est la
phrase que vous posez à chpt ça peut
être une question une affirmation et
vous lui demandez de continuer et
l'interpréte a ation qu'on fait de ces
mots est lié au grand corpus qu'il y a
derrière donc on projette qu'elle a des
connaissances peut-être plus que nous
qu'elle serait un jour peut-être plus
rationnelle que nous c'est faux elle est
tout sauf neutre toutes ces qualités
morales viennent de ce qu'on a mis en
fait comme algorithme et dans le corpus
donc vous faites de la pédagogie il y a
beaucoup de choses qui vous agacent un
ouvrage sur l'homme augmenté un certain
nombre de de débats il y a il y a la
question éthique il y a la question de
l'éducation il y a la question
économique jusqu'où il faut penser le
grand remplacement des méti
il y a déjà des métiers qui ont disparu
tous les métiers de synthèse les revues
de presse les interprètes sont vraiment
très
angoissés on est armé est-ce que vous
trouvez que le débat public politique
est àbat politique est à côté de la
plaque je vais le dire clairement par
exemple dans ces systèmes c'est
majoritairement de l'anglais he 80 %
l'anglais or notre langue elle passe
notre culture nos opinions notre
politique et là je il faut absolument
faire attention si demain parce que
c'est moins cher on va aller chercher
des cœurs de LLM de ces larges langag
modèles qui sont au cœur donc des chat
GPT et autres pour les instruire les
utiliser et apprendre sur du français
qu'est-ce qu'on est en train de faire
donc on a besoin de quantifier
d'optimiser tout ça en ayant une
meilleure connaissance de tout ce qui
est à l'intérieur et je pense que la
réglementation est importante et la
normalisation l' aussi et je ne
comprends pas une chose ici c'est que le
le les Américains hein qu'on met si
souvent en exemple parce que ils ont
réussi beaucoup de choses qu'on arrive
pas à faire soi-disant et bien Biden son
gouvernement s'intéresse aux normes le
nôtre demandez-leur un petit peu ce
qu'il pensent des normes c'est
antiinnovation vous n trouvez vous nous
trouvez en ça en matière de régulation
en matière de la régulation et l'éthique
c'est en fait il il y a trois sujets un
premier pilier qui est que tout le monde
comprenne ce que c'est que l'éthique
c'est un outil pour comprendre s'il y a
des avantages des inconvénients et c'est
jamais blanc ou noir c'est toujours du
gris on va chercher à optimiser cas à
cas sur des verticales sur des sujets
particulier la santé va faire beaucoup
de bon en avant l'écologie sans doute
aussi on va apprendre mieux ce qui ce
que nous sommes grâce à CIA donc faut
absolument aller dans ces domaines là
deuxième moyen ce sont des lois mais il
faut pas aller trop vite dans les lois
et je pense qu'on va en Europe trop vite
parce qu'il faut des lois mondiales si
nous sommes les seuls à faire des lois
c'est un problème je pense que alors les
lois mondial pour l'instant on on a pas
c'est quasiment impossible il faut uvrer
dans ce sens-là de plus en plus même si
elles sont moins rigides et d'ailleurs
elles le sont beaucoup trop ce que
propose la la loi sur l'IA c'est quelque
chose qui est sûrement trop fort pour
maintenant et qui est pas produit par
des gens qui sont suffisamment au fait
de ces technologie le troisème P ce sont
les normes et les normes ce sont les
industriels qui les font avec les
académiques en discutant avec le
gouvernement Biden par exemple ce qu'on
ne sait pas faire en France un exemple
de norme précisément je peux avoir une
norme vous connaissez tous les normes je
sais pas sur les jouets on interdit avec
les petits objets que les enfants
touchent des objets enfin des peluches
qui sont dangereuses parce qu'il des
petits objets ça il pourrait les avaler
on a une norme là-dessus pour dire
attention il a besoin de sécurité pensez
qu'un jour on devra avoir une sorte de
label fait par l'humain euh certifié
humain comme on a fabriqué en France ou
fait maison faut il faut absolument
qu'on fasse attention à la frontière
entre ce qu'on est en train de produire
qui ressemble à l'humain je pense au
journalisme par exemple la production de
texes synthétiques qui viennent de
machine sans conscience sans intention
en ayant perdu toutes les sources donc
sans vérifier la véracité des prot ça
c'est un vrai sujet et je pense que là
on a besoin de mettre au moins au
minimum des watermarkson appelle les
filigrames dans les textes produit pour
prouver que ça vient d'une machine et il
faut falloir faire attention à ce qu'on
utilise dans les prochains systèmes
est-ce que l'apprentissage sera fait à
partir de données synthéthique pour
aller encore plus loin finalement dans
une perte d'intelligence collective
notre intelligence elle vient de
l'ensemble de notre langage que l'on
partage attention à ces machines merci
beaucoup Laurence de Viller un robot ne
pourra jamais comprendre ce que nous
ressentons ni nos affects qui a ACC
garoutia on peut le trouver à quelle
quelle maison d'édition alors vous
pouvez le trouver au théâtre au CF CF
édition bien c'est facile à trouver et
peut-être sur scène bientôt après et
j'espère à Paris bientôt si on trouv un
producteur on l'a joué un peu partout en
province on cherche quelqu'un sur Paris
c'est ben le message est passé je pense
que c'est très drôle et très instructif
merci beaucoup vous allez voir on va
continuer en parler de Lia dans Les
Affranchis nos chroniqueurs on les
accueille tout de
suite Delphine Sabatier de bmart l'œil
sur le numérique qui va nous parler
justement de de la menace que fait peser
l'Italie sur Chat GPT et Vincent UG
grand reporter pour l'Internationale
installez-vous on commence par bonbon
Express bien sûr l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée elle amondinava bonsoir
bonsoir cette histoire je vais commencer
par piquer une anecdote à notre confrère
du Figaro Wally Bordas qui raconte ce
matin avoir vu Eric cioti debout t un
député de la majorité pour accueillir
Gabriel hatal montant à la tribune hier
pour sa déclaration de politique
générale moi j'en ai pas cru mes
oreilles et comme dans le foot quand il
a un doute on demande la vie vidéo
regardez ces images c'était hier dans
l'hémicycle la parole est à Monsieur le
Premier
Ministre la présidente de l'Assemblée
donne la parole au Premier ministre les
députés de la majorité sont donc debout
et puis a un député de droite debout sa
collègue Véronique louvagi lui sble lui
dire mais qu'est-ce que tu fabriques
Éric rassie-toi je te rappelle qu'on est
dans l'opposition ça fait bien marrer
tous les collègues à côté bonti il a pas
l'air traumatisé il en rigole après on
s'est demandé si cette scène finalement
c'était pas un acte manqué est-ce
qu'Eric cotti il l'avait lu avant il
avait peut-être prédit tiens le discours
de Gabriel hatal et il avait bien senti
que le tout nouveau Premier ministre
allait virer cap à droite toute
combattre toutes les trappes à
inactivité le fardeau des règles et des
normes il faut assumer d'accueillir
moins pour accueillir mieux quand on a
rendez-vous chez le médecin et qu'on ne
vient pas sans prévenir on paye on ne
négocie pas avec la République on
l'accepte on la respecte nous devons
faire respecter l'autorité partout dans
les classes dans les familles dans les
rues tu casses tu répares tu sies tu
nettoies tu défies l'autorité on
t'apprend à la respecter l'impunité
c'est fini alors comment ils réagissent
à droite les républicains ça leur plaît
ces motsl ou ça leur bouffe leur espace
en fait bah un petit peu des deux c'est
vrai qu'on les a interrogé ce matin ils
sont bien obligés de reconnaître que
Gabriel Attal allit tout juste au pire
leur pique leur vocabulaire hier quand
vous écoutiez le discours de Gabriel at
vous aviez l'impression d'entendre un
discours de droite vous vous êtes dit
bah tiens ça pourrait être quelqu'un de
chez moi je me suis pas dit ça mais les
mots étaient clairement et la sémantique
était clairement plus à droite qu'à
gauche et d'une certaine manière tant
mieux ça veut dire qu'on a un gain
idéologique c'est clair qu'il y a des
mots sur l'autorité sur l'identité sur
le travail qui correspondent à des
propositions qu'on a formulé après le
vrai sujet c'est est-ce qu'il va être
capable de passer de la parole aux actes
alors j'ai demandé à un conseiller de
l'ombre à droite he si trouvait que
Gabriel hatal ressemblait un peu à
Nicolas Sarkozi il a explosé de rire en
disant que Sarkozi était bien plus à
gauche plus sérieusement la droite on le
sait elle a du mal à exister coincé
entre l'extrême droite et la majorité en
ce moment c'est difficile ce même
conseiller me dit bien avec Atal il
efface complètement LR ce que la droite
a fantasmé Atal le fait ceux qui sont
absolument ravis bah c'est ceux qu' ont
déjà franchi le Rubicon qui sont passés
de la droite à la majorité ça ne fait
que conforter leur choix écoutez Robin
Reda Gabriel était le porte-parole le
porte-voie des Français et je pense que
les Français et les Français ils
attendent un premier ministre à leur
côté qui les défend et qui fait preuve
de bon sens un premier ministre de
droite avec du bon sens de droite
écoutez quelqu'un qui en tout cas parle
concrètement et parle avec le cœur parle
avec bon sens moi j'ai essayé de lui
faire prononcer le mot droite mais
c'était ni oui ni non ni droite il l'a
pas dit mais dans le fond effectivement
ça penchait à droite et c'est pas pour
déplaire à cette partie de la majorité
merci
beaucoupagava vous le reconnaissez
Emmanuel Macron et Gabriel beaucoup
changé j'ai rien à dire là je allez on
enchaîne là je suis sûr que vous allez
pouvoir réagir avec Delphine Sabatier on
apprend que tiadibit est accusé par
l'Italie de violer la loi européenne
l'intelligence artificielle pourrait
être interdite en Europe en tout cas
l'Italie semble assez déterminé c'est le
second coup qu'elle porte à Chad GPT
depuis son son lancement là
l'intelligence artificielle américaine a
30 jours pour réagir faut noter aussi
qu'on a d'autres pays européens qui sont
motés au créneau contre TAD GPT mais pas
la France he qui est plutôt silencieuse
sur le sujetors quoi tubti contevient à
la loi alors l'Italie dit avoir des
preuves de violation de la loi sur la
confidentialité en fait c'est la suite
de sa première contestation on se
rappelle en mars au moment de des
premières utilisations en Europe de chat
GPT les autorités italiennes ont bloqué
temporairement l'intelligence
artificielle parce qu'elle s'inquiétait
en fait de la manière dont l'outil
récupérait les données de ses
concitoyens et puis la manière aussi
dont elle les utilisait l'Italie a quand
même trouvé dans le logiciel des
informations de paiement des
conversations d'utilisateur alors elle
dénonçait aussi le fait qu'il y avait
aucune protection pour les enfants qui
pouvaient être face à des réponses qui
n'étaient pas du tout adaptées à leur
âge voire à des contenus choquants ou
interdits aux mineurs et puis en France
on a à peu près au même moment des
plaintes qui ont été déposées auprès de
laacnil là aussi par des citoyens qui
dénonçaient en gros l'opacité sur les
informations personnelles détenu par
chat GPT ou encore sa capacité à dire à
peu près n'importe quoi sur sur les gens
et la France elle ne bouge pas
manifestement pourquoi alors en tout cas
on a pas de nouvelles de ces plaintes
l'acnil à qui j'ai posé la question sur
leur devenir m'a répondu qu'en fait ils
avaient dû attendre que open ai qui est
derrière donc Chad GPT est vraiment un
siège en tout cas une présence
officielle en Europe pour transmettre ce
dossier disons qu'on aurait pu penser en
tout cas je pensais que la France aurait
une position beaucoup plus ferme en
matière de traitement des données
personnelles car enfin faut rappeler que
his historiquement quand même on a été
pionnier sur la protection de la vie
privée dans le numérique avec notre loi
Informatique et Liberté de
1968 et pourtant là bah on attend un peu
comme les discussions aujourd'hui en
Europe autour d'un règlement sur
l'intelligence artificielle où on trouve
la France finalement avec une position
beaucoup plus souple que de nombreux
États
européens alors elle ne s'en cache pas
en fait hein elle elle décide clairement
de soutenir l'innovation espérant faire
émerger ses propres champion européen
futur champion dont il ne faudrait pas
entraver la course avec des contraintes
qui seraient lourdes et très complexe à
mettre en œuvre réaction Laurence de
Viller cette menace d'interdiction de de
l'Italie est-ce que est-ce qu'elle va
dans le bon sens je pense que c'est pas
c'est pas idiot de comprendre quand même
que ces machines parlent pas du tout
avec notre culture hein on a 80 % ou
plus de donné en anglais hein dans ces
machines donc ça veut dire que à un
moment donné quand on l'inviewit chat
GPT on lui demander quelle est la fête
nationale ben on avait le 4 juillet donc
ils l'ont un peu réparé depuis ça donne
plus cette réponse mais bon voilà il y a
une incidence forte donc il faut qu'on
fasse avec des LLM et on sait le faire
avec les mêmes outils on peut très bien
faire des objets francophones des objets
mélangeant des Lang mais sur la
captation de données sur lequel on sera
plus maître de comprendre sur la
captation de don c'est autre chose je
trouve que là il y a quelque chose qu'on
doit absolument comprendre les données
privées arrêtons arrêtons avec ce cette
comment dire cette idée folle que
peut-être demain faudrait qu'on me paye
pour mes données ou des choses comme ça
c'est aberrant si on veut demain
travailler sur avec des objets qui
soient intelligents pour nous il faut
leur donner nos données il faut par
exemple que pour la santé les données
soient accessibles il faut créer des
communs la société marche avec des
communs c'estàd des valeurs ensemble ces
objets ils sont capables d'être très
utiles pour détecter des nouvelles
maladies comprendre mieux comment on
utilise l'énergie donc quand j'entends
des gens qui avaient peur par exemple du
du truc de linging là je sais pas quoi
qui Calc cul votre consommation c'était
absurde on s'en fiche de leur donné vous
rendez compte parce que il y a pas que
des données pour la santé il y a numéro
de carte bleue l'adresse personnelle il
s'agit pas de prendre votre numéro de
carte bleue ni d'aller dire à votre
employeur que vous avez un problème
médical ok donc il y a des choses qu'il
faut absolument réglementer anonymiser
mais il y a des tas de données qui sont
pas personnelles d'ailleurs votre génome
il est personnel à votre avis bah non il
appartient aussi à vos parents donc on a
une aberration dans cette idée de
données personnelles on englopee tout et
je pense qu'on a besoin à nouveau
d'éduquer de qu'est-ce que c'est
vraiment et quels sont les niveaux qu'on
a besoin de partager dans la société
pour arriver à faire des outils
performant innovant qui soit en avance
donc vous êtes plutôt sur la ligne
française attention à pas brider
l'innovation je suis pas sur la ligne
française parce que je trouve qu'il y a
eu des abus et je pense que il faudrait
être plus vigilant en France sur ce
qu'on est en train de faire au niveau
politique c'est dit un mot de réaction
très rapide oui peut-être plus de
transparence parce qu'en fait
aujourd'hui la question c'est ça c'est
quelles sont ces données qui sont
utilisées pour former ces algorithmes
hein euh on n pas beaucoup de réponses
pour l'instant allez on enchaîne parce
que je voudrais qu'on laisse de l'espace
et du temps surtout à à Vincent euh
Vincent 12 pays dont les États-Unis ont
annoncé la suspension de leur
contribution financière à
l'UNRWA c'est une agence de l'ONU dont
plusieurs employés ont pris part au
massacre du 7 octobre alors avant tout
une piqûure de rappel factuelle hein
l'uneri kzako ce sigle quasiment
imprononçable c'est l'acronyme anglais
d'agence de secours et de travaux des
Nations Unies fondé en décembre 1949 18
mois après la création de l'État
d'Israël et son corollaire l'expulsion
ou la fuite de 700000 Arabes de
Palestine ce service ununien a vocation
depuis lors à fournir protection et
assistance aux réfugiés palestiniens
dans la bandne de Gaza et en 6 Jordanie
occupé certes mais pas seulement Liban
Jordanie Irak Syrie près de 6 millions
de déracinés dépendent d'une manière
d'une autre de l'agence qu'il s'agit
d'alimentation de santé de logement ou
d'éducation autant dire qu'en lui
coupant les vivre les pays donateurs
prennent le risque de plonger dans le
chaos une région en équilibre instable
sans pour autant servir les intérêts
d'Israël qui n'a aucune envie de se
substituer à l'institution qu'elle
accable depuis des lustres de griief h
alors grief justifié ou pas soyons clair
n'aurait-on identifié qu'un seul employé
de luneeri parmi les auteurs de
l'abjecte carnage du 7 octobre que
l'impact sur l'image de l'agence n'en
serait pas moins ravageur celle-ci
a-t-elle failli nombre de ces cadres
passés ou présent de l'an m et le nier
serait inepte oui de l'armement a été
planqué dans des écoles ou des cliniques
oui l'enseignement dispensé rela ça et
là les poncifs les plus éculés de la
propagande antisémite oui de nombreux
salariés de lune roi gravide dans
l'orbite du Hamas ou du Djihad islamique
mais de grâce trêve d'hypocrisie comment
pourrait-il en être autrement comment
les recruts locales qui partagent depuis
l'enfance le fardeau de leur congénère
précarité servitude et pénurie totale
d'espérance qu'en prê-elle sur une ligne
de not neutralité évétique d'autant qu'à
Gaza les islamistes exercent depuis 2006
un pouvoir tyrannique le marteau de Sal
et l'enclame du Hamas on connait la
rangain al c'est la seule hypocrisie à
laquelle vous pensez non bien sûr la
séquence a de quoi troubler ce serait
faire un jure au renseignement
d'israëlien que de supposer qu'il a
découvert la semaine dernière les
collusions dénoncées or l'État hébreu
dégainne son réquisitoire le lendemain
du jugement de la Cour international de
justice de lae lui enjoignant de
prévenir tout acte de génocide à
l'instar de la plupart de ces Pr esseur
benjamine detanou considère l'ONU et ses
agences l'une roi au premier chef mais
aussi l'OMS pour la santé ou l'UNESCO
côté culture comme des ennemis du peuple
juif qu'il faut à tout prix discréditer
sans doute parce que l'étandard des
Nations Unies flottait déjà sur le plan
de partage avorté de 1948 lequel
instaurait le droit au retour des exilés
Palestiniens péchés originel inexpiable
au-delà du caractère indéfendable de
tout châtiment collectif qu'il prennent
la forme de bombardement dévastateur ou
de l'étranglement financier d'un
opérateur humanitaire vital le procès
fait à lune roi mérite l'oscar de la
duplicité car enfin qui sécurisait
l'acheminement entre DOA et Gaza via
l'aéroport Bouron du pactol mensuel 30
millions de dollars dont le Qatar
gratifiait les autorités de la bande
doncle Hamas qui les services secrets
d'Israël et puisqu'il est question de
tartuferie et d'argent le nerf de la
guerre a défaut d'être celui de la paix
cet ultime remarque les cinq principaux
donateurs de lune roi étaient
jusqu'alors occidentaux point d'Arabie
Saoudite ni de Turquie dans ce Ploton de
tête et pas l'ombre d'un émirat du golf
chercher l'erreur merci voilà un parti
prê je rappelle que la France n'a pas
suspendu hein son son aide à cette
agence de l'ONU merci les affranchis
merci Elsa et merci infiniment Laurence
de Viller lia d'ailleurs qui est très
présente hein dans dans la guerre à Gaza
avec la possibilité de géolocaliser les
cibles évaluer les victimes merci
beaucoup vous reviendrai j'espère parce
qu'on a pas fini hein de
transm et d'éduquer sur ces sujets c'est
la de cette émission très bonne soirée
documentaire qui commence maintenant
avec Jean-Pierre gracien à
[Musique]
demain